we let's talk about the polling we all
must be cautious careful and diligent in
our participation in this election we
all must vote we almost
get people to vote but as a brief
interlude to our discussion of the last
24 hours
polling has completely imploded this
week for donald trump i'm going to go
through with you
all of the new polling now that we are
just 25 26 days from the election
and it is a very veritable disaster for
donald trump if these numbers are even
remotely accurate and if voter
suppression and dirty tricks
don't end up being how trump claws his
way back up
this could be really bad for trump if if
if
if we vote and remember this polling is
all
post-first debate and it is post-trump
getting coronavirus
and pulling his covita stunt on the
white house portico
so first nationally joe biden is plus
nine
in a new poll plus 10 in a new poll
and shockingly plus 12 in a new
rasmussen poll typically one of the most
right-wing polls that we have
if you look overall at recent national
polls this now pushes joe biden's
advantage to an
average of 9.4 points over donald trump
as you can see in the trend lines it is
not going in the right direction for
trump the recent reversal
with a trump decline and biden ascension
started on september 29th that's where
we've seen this drop for trump start
september 29th now let's not go crazy
we still have almost four weeks to go if
we look at trump versus hillary
26 days out from the election back in
2016 remember in 2016 the election was
on november 8
so if we go back 26 days from the 2016
election
hillary's lead was 6.7 so yes
joe biden's lead today is bigger than
hillary's four years ago
but hillary was also climbing at this
point in 2016
and biden's lead now is only 40
bigger than hillary's was you might
remember i told you a few days ago
biden's lead today is a hundred and
forty percent bigger than hillary's was
at this point four years ago biden's
lead is growing but hillary's was
growing even more quickly at this point
in time so let's just
understand that not become complacent
now let's look at some state polls
remember we have an electoral college
system
in this country where each state is
worth a certain number of electoral
votes 270 being the total you need
to clinch the presidency the latest
state polls
are very bad for trump yesterday we had
a new marquette poll
for wisconsin and biden is plus five
that's good for biden
ohio according to new york times sienna
biden is
plus one if biden wins ohio you can
essentially say goodbye to donald trump
in pennsylvania from emerson biden is
plus five
but then we have a quinnipiac poll which
has biden
up 13 in pennsylvania 11
in florida which is just incredible and
five
in iowa and then also notable yesterday
uh new york times sienna poll says biden
is up six
in nevada and even the poll out of west
virginia that says trump is up 18
remember that in 1919
in 2016 a trump won west virginia by 42.
if indeed trump wins west virginia by
only 18
that would be a very small margin of
victory in one of the reddest states
in the country so the debate clearly did
not work well for donald trump having
coronavirus pulling his corona ride and
covida stunts
have not helped him and now we will wait
and see
what the impact of the vice presidential
debate is
if any let me know what you think it
will be
i'm on twitter at deepakman real quick i
want to tell you about our sponsor
magic spoon who have done something
awesome they've taken
all of our favorite sugary childhood
cereals that we know we shouldn't eat
anymore
and turn them into something you can
actually feel good about eating as an
adult
there's four flavors cocoa fruity
frosted and blueberry
they taste great they're crunchy they're
sweet like you would expect this type of
cereal to be
but it's perfect for a ketogenic diet
because one bowl has only
three net carbs 12 grams of protein it's
sugar-free
gluten-free grain-free soy-free
once our team tried magic spoon for the
first time we actually ended up emailing
magic spoon back and saying can you send
us
more boxes send more samples they've
been a big hit
with david pakman's show staffers and
magic spoon
knows how delicious their cereal is
because if you don't like it they'll
refund all of your money no questions
asked
and you'll get free shipping when you go
to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman that's
p-a-k-m-a-n